[Musique]
cherry et bien la place de cali et ben
tu admires stéphane plaza qui l'adorent
c'est vrai c'est un animateur préféré
oui donc deuxième c'est un premier bail
que tu as fait voilà n'allait pas dans
les papiers soient payés de fabsoul au
coeur d'un moment tu nous dire si tu
peux razr ce quelque chose tu le sais
j'ai fait d'accord t'inquiète pas
d'accord et si tu veux même gisement
room-service quelque chose qui me garde
bien avant la fin de l'émission à ce que
tu as des marchés actions regardez cet
extrait de recherche appartement ou
maison
alors que va-t-il se passer
stéphane plaza va passer à travers
l'escalier stéphane plaza baratine
marché tomber sur le cameraman ou
stéphane plaza va recroiser gérard
louvin sur son monte escalier labéda
bidabé david habib l'abbé web et elle
est très bien dans le rôle
ces biens ont été fabuleux on regarde
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est amusant de là il arrive et loga
l'unif attention parce que y'a les
canalisations derrière il arrive en
effet mélangez pas fait exprès mais ça
ça va ça s'est arrangé pas encore mais
bon pour l'instant ils font pipi fois
plus à dit oui ouais ça va s'arranger on
avait failli faire contient au moins un
moment fort et béziers franchement on
aurait rigolé va trop loin trop lourde
et c est ce que vous rappelle la série
de france télévisions le groupe
oui c'est avec sandra lou regardez moi
j'ai pas j'ai alors que va t il se
passer
stéphane plaza va arriver avec des
fleurs stéphane plaza va embrasser
sandra lou ou stéphane plaza va
découvrir que l'appartement fait
seulement 38 arrêts loi thérèse la
halabi l'abbé l'habitude de garder moi
je dis là est la bay area fleurs elle
embrasse maps et chaud là bas je sais
pas j'ai pas vu la suite hein mais tu
laboures est quand même joué dans un bon
tournoi
ces patates par jean pierre pernaut
arradon pardon alors oui alors là il
avait fait et ça non je m'ouvre la porte
et j'embrasse cannes bien d'autres pays
a dû couper avant ah ouais bah attendent
et choukook soudan avant on regardait
problème bonjour j'ai un bouquet pour
géraldine et un autre pour sandra s'est
attardé qui il a marqué freiner julien
désolé c'est une finale et puis si on va
peut-être pouvoir leur faire parvenir
donner les bons
sandra tu l'aimés dans un vase s'il te
plaît et ça c'est pour pourvoir
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dis-moi faire tu partes en safari
c'est quoi cette chemise à faire savoir
you can à pékin express avec isabelle
morini bosc
elle est mignonne mais c'était il ya
longtemps mais n'a pas trop changé
je te jure que c'est vrai à part le bras
mais elle si vous la meilleure chose qui
pourrait vous arriver c'est de changer
d'humour
non vraiment la waci c'est pas ça allait
très vite une très jolie oui ça me fait
plaisir pour toi merci on va regarder
une vidéo lors qu'on a retrouvé sur
instagram d'ailleurs je vous rappelle
que si stéphane plaza passe à 30 milles
sur un stade on fera un gros match au
ping pong à roland garros vous invitera
tous data 19 399 il te manque plus de
10000 c'est parti on y va on suit
stéphane plaza stéphane plaza offre qui
est toujours of travaille jamais donner
des accents le maire a ajouté un arrêt
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m voilà une vidéo donc on l'a trouvé sur
un ton instagram de ses fans le début de
la vidéo vous allez reconnaître
sophie ferjani oui à l'égard des manifs
inanimé sur deux tonnes en maison avant
de décéder travaux ces gros bazar je
vais vous montrer quand même ce qui se
passe chez nous pour vous voyez alors
quand va-t-il se passer
on va découvrir stéphane plaza aux
toilettes on va découvrir stéphane banda
sous la douche on va découvrir stéphane
plaza faire l'amour sur une double
vasque
or la douche tous la douche et toilettes
toilettes toilettes et douches sont
douces et d'aménager la basse ou voulez
mais encore plus de pluie que vous le
voyez aujourd'hui
non mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien
c'est bien beau sourire et tout y'a un
truc pour de vrai vrai en plus j'accepte
je veux bien qu'on dit d'ensemble
j'accepte
assurer la question et pas de dîner la
question qui prend sa carte bleue à la
haye va vous invitez je crois
on voit là et bien là quoi quoi avec la
toute petite note de frais
[Rires]
il faut du talent unique
[Applaudissements]
je vous rappelle que il un bal au
théâtre des deux ânes
non mesdames messieurs seniors
pour anne orange pourrait franchement
ils préparent un petit truc avant avant
la fin de l'émission un petit truc un
petit poème ou un truc trop coûteux non
sinon non claudine on voudra cent poèmes
d'une bande annonce avec qui tu pourrais
pas toi chaque fois quelqu'un il leur
ait du tout et avec ben c'est quand même
autre chose
le dernier le dernier a pas que j'ai
voulu choquer dans l'émission
franchement à part vous ça remonte à
très longtemps c'est rachid arhab
[Applaudissements]
battus aussi mais non c'est matt pokora
non c'est vous les pêcheries de matt
pokora separate états unis n'étaient pas
de bagarres sont la douce regarder oui
j'ai une salle de bain avec un disque
s'écoule c'est pas dantesques un halo et
visiblement les 15 jours ou tag heuer et
12 c 'est pas le c'était patrick est
annoncé le tahiti dont je veux parler
des choix des images japon selon
regardèrent vous avez des problèmes de
vue ça prend de la cour jusqu'à c'est le
pommeau de douche et oui merci que
j'avais coincé entre mes jambes
les voitures et là elle sait reconnaître
pour vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette vidéo concerne les pmp
regardez c'est quoi la suite ce qu'il
fallait pas louper d'accueillir camille
combal je souhaite qu'on accueille notre
ami stéphane plaza qui est prêt alors
que va-t-il se passer
stéphane plaza va arriver sur le plateau
mylène farmer stéphane plaza va
débarquer en caleçon ou stéphane plaza
va se tromper de ce château est arrivé
et il a beau mot non alors qu'elle saute
pas je te rappelle ce big band big band
big band pascal son big ben oui c'est
vrai que tu avais toujours à leur propre
à toi confiance quand même le hblm
gérez-vous compte qu'après monte bien
ces martyrs regarder on y va en régime
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est magnifique ça serait bien
il est parti à l'ordre c'est vrai sans
rappeler tous bords alors mathieu basse
et qui adore du monde il avait il ajouté
des clémentines y avait un truc en plus
à eelv et intrigant plus haut trop chaud
cet arrêté
rien rien mathieu nom très mal ça me
ferait mal mathieu n'existe à bichât on
a un gars qui nous regarde tout le temps
là aussi lui il aime ton émission on n a
rien et calme toi quand même bravo tout
cas jamais aimé les deux toiles enfin
surtout de votre côté ça y va bah ouais
moi choisir je passe cromheecke karine
lemarchand je m'aperçois vous avez bien
raison tu as bien raison non mais c'est
sûr ces virages on aurait pu vous faire
chier
ouais j'ai déjà tout payer c'est vrai
que c'est le problème de vote lundi
qu'elles font partie de soirée avec
karine et puis après le deuxième partie
de soirée un petit verre et tout ça est
en fait c'est quand même la grève
s'annonce incertaine saga les experts
vient de croiser la prière les experts
experts si je redis flux allez on va
regarder d'un air extrait brahim extrait
de chasseurs d'appart la donne à votre
avis c'est quoi la suite
regardez la vidéo alors ça claque là
quatre attaques
stéphane plaza va faire une bague
coquine stéphane plaza va se lever et
faire un flamenco ou stéphane plaza va
rendre hommage à l'athlète de joey starr
à gilles verdez coquine coquine et comme
tu parles de ça claque
pardon au sérieux
ça me fait penser une petite levrette sa
part sa surface bien surtout parce c'est
vrai avec humour on voit bien c'est non
mais c'est vrai que ça va moi
franchement y'a rien de vulgaire là
dedans c'est ça passe comme une lettre à
la poste
regardez cet extrait de la bande
centrale donne quoi comme il est de
tradition est restée cinq claviers vous
présente cette année les nuits son
tablier
je vais demander je vais demander à
toutes les personnes de se retourner
toutes les personnes du public
on a tout vu que personne ne voit cet
extrait tous les chroniqueurs à pains à
matthieu delormeau vous allez regarder
seuls ces textes moi juste vous faire
kiffer allez vous regarder il est nu
tous habillés moi je ne regarde pas ok
mathieu et vous mettrez une note
ok attention c'est parti érection par
action devrait pas diminuer classe à
bercy et qui ne se prend pas au sérieux
titi respecte pas bull va très bien
d'accord non alors honnêtement j'aime
alors ce sont ces feuilles et vous devez
jouer au tennis non je trompé de balle
ben non ça c'est des fêtes de sportifs
et c'est des fesses de tennisman
bah oui ça je peux vous en dire bien sûr
c'est excellent
[Musique]
ces défaites tu vois ça c'est des fesses
de mec qui fait du curling ça y est les
muscles et ici elle est bien galbées
franchement honnêtement ça sur 10 6 1
108 et demi ça à huit et demi à peine
ils étaient venus pour agathe il va
porter avec de l'endroit à bâle
je vais partir avec mon taxi tous